je sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais
depuis février dernier le prix du lait a
augmenté d'environ 1,5 pour cent soit 2
2 à 3 cents de plus le litre
les prix du lait sont fixés sur le
territoire du québec selon quatre
régions et ça ne concerne que les led
base tous les laits à valeur ajoutée
comme les ultras filtrer ou encore les
biologique ne sont pas touchés par ce
règlement
la régie des marchés agricoles et
alimentaires du québec décident d'un
prix minimum et d'un prix maximum
d'élèves base et tous les détails en
épicerie dépanneur pharmacies doivent
respecter six prix mais surveillez les
biens parce qu'encore l'automne dernier
on vous a démontré clairement que près
de la moitié des petits commerces
visités ne respectez pas les tarifs
imposés
consultez notre site internet pour
connaître ses nouveaux prix et vous
pouvez porter plainte si jamais on ne
vous voit pas votre lait à bon prix